the girag an experience you are feeling
when I go to pitch a I'll go to pitch a
me an idea about a new show or something
right and they're like this one guys is
like that's a horrible idea don't ever
tell anyone that idea again whoa that's
always the best idea I've found like if
an executive sucks go go digital and do
it cuz they don't fuckin care
I have an idea once that I pitched over
the phone and the guy actually like said
you're kidding right you did you waste
my time with this and I was like wow
alright I guess you didn't like my idea
I pitched over the phone he was like I
go I have this idea for a show it's just
a silly idea but it's like it's a comedy
and it's about these girls that work at
a bikini pizza place in the day called
Pizza sluts and at night they fight
crime and they're there they're super
hot chicks that are recruited by the
police force and trained to infiltrate
into areas where other cops could never
get Jennifers people would never believe
that these hot girls were actually
secret agents yeah why did they have to
work at the place is that a full-time
job though well because they have a
cover thought and you know where this
mark and fucking dude was mad at me this
is Chuck I pitched it that dude was Matt
is a long time ago by the way and the
dude was mad at me I was like I think
that would be a silly show like you
don't think they could be like a ton of
jokes and like you'd get 2 million
viewers just completely over the top
have you ever pitched something just to
fuck with the money no have you waste
time with me sometimes yeah yeah because
this is not at first this was I took I
mean like I I make my money helping
people right and I make my real money as
may known speeches like I go to do
motivational speeches at colleges
teaching kids to get their shit together
and stop being lazy it's up to stop
being a whiny little bitch speech it's
it's this entitlement buy college kids
and colleges really like me coming and I
do an hour speech and then a half-hour
Q&A and then I'll do a lot of podcast
it's great I mean for me that's amazing
money it changes our family's life right
so now it's like if I can do TV great if
I don't that's fine too I'd like to do
it but like I'll have an idea I had a
idea of quarter road trip I just wanted
to take
bunch of hoarders in a Winnebago take
across country and make him clean up
someone else's house that's a good idea
I think be fascinated yes like country
right at first it was a joke but then
the more I started pitching it I was
like actually Alex I like seed Ignis but
the first time I was just trying to piss
off the executive because he had sat on
my pilot for a year and so I was just
mad at him he sat on the pilot I did
I've done two pilots and I didn't
realize this is everyone's done ten
pilots it is what it is don't worry
about it I was devastated because my
first pilot didn't make show really yeah
I was devastated devastated I was like
this is gonna I mean I really I put all
my eggs in that basket and I was just
emotionally and I was like this is so
important that I get this show and by
the time the network and the production
company and I got done with it was a
shitty show and I didn't want to do it
and I was like praying that it wouldn't
get too picked up but then when it
didn't get picked up I got all upset I
got I got personal with it and I just
I've learned now it is what it is it's
just business it's it's really hard to
be on a show and watch it fall apart
because too many people have their input
and this fuck with and I had no input
yeah you know and it was like my name's
on this my company's name is on it and
it doesn't in it I mean well executive
always think they always think they have
a way to tweak it to make it better yes
I'm not saying I'm brilliant or anything
I was just I was personally upset I
think that you know the the
collaborative effort like a real true
creative collaborative effort only works
with people who respect each other
creatively like people who actually are
proven to be creative in order to bring
someone like an executive into a
creative meeting like what are you a
creative person you would you write a
lot I mean you're gonna have good ideas
or is this like an ego bullshit thing
here your greasy fingerprints on this
and at your little ingredients to soup
that's what a lot of it is and I got I
mean I'm but with hoarders there's no
writing we turn the cameras on and shit
happens yeah and that's it it's your
show no I'm just talent on that how many
different dudes are quarter cleaners
we've got wells to really like I mean
there's a lot of people that that try to
do it but in the it's like a hit show
right oh yeah you know I say I'm the
number one trash man in the country and
A&E has no problem with you doing all
your other stuff where they just never
even sign me to come name it on a
contract you're not on a contract
I'm week-to-week whoa it's crazy that's
gonna be annoying I'm the number
gaion you know their number to show it
amazes me I'm fine I don't want a
contract now like doesn't contract I
couldn't come do this like I'm you said
it best the other day on your podcast
you go I'm doing what I should be doing
you're doing it right now
and I'm their man my PI I'm doing I
wrote a book had a great run with my
book I'm helping a lot of families with
my book it's called secret lives of
Hoarders so you're just happy to keep
moving work direction and keep working I
clean up shit for 12 bucks an hour I'm
happy to be working period like I'm
lucky to have work III can afford all my
groceries and my mortgage in the same
month I'm lucky like that's awesome